hey guys how's it going so I am pretty
excited for today's video because we are
going to be making a Nintendo switch
themed Donuts if you're wondering how
that's gonna happen I'm also wondering
the same thing I've got something in
mind that I think is gonna work out
fairly well I'm hoping and I want to
celebrate the launch others had to
switch March their babies March yeah
here we've got some donut shop donut mix
so I've made donuts before on my channel
and if they've worked out okay but I
thought this would be so much easier
because it's basically donuts in a box
I've messed things up in boxes before so
there's a possibility of messing this up
I mean nothing is ever guaranteed let's
start it six tablespoons of melted
butter 3 eggs 3/4 large milk cup milk
large what am I even saying hey here's
my milk I just got this on Amazon just
showed up it's about great six
tablespoons melted butter but you in
here I can't believe actually to melt
the butter usually it's just as softened
but today melting is for real what's
happening here
I don't know hopefully it melts three
large eggs one two
three yep that's the absolutely this
this this is its boy it's actually
boiling so that's cool
let's get that mixed up real nice at our
butter
[Applause]
with an electric mixer cream on medium
speed until well incorporated well in
all right
young Shane
[Music]
scrape those sides baby make sure you
spray the pan spray I have two pins I'm
not sure how much this is gonna make I I
am Not sure we're gonna find out I feel
like I could probably make two out of
that says to fill your little bill nuts
about 3/4 of the way I got this cute
little bottle I kind of want to try it
squeeze little kick mix into the thing
will this work will this work
[Music]
I think it's working
that tastes really good Wow now we're
just gonna squeeze it right in here mmm
see here's the problem
I didn't account for the sprinkles that
were in here that's causing a little bit
of a backup is not at all when I have a
plan it's on at all what I had planned
god great well
got a carry on carry on my would so this
is a bad idea this was this was probably
the worst idea that I've ever had not
sought the worst I've ever had and
definitely bad worse it's gonna work out
very well scoop that over there sounds a
little bit too full scoop you in here
maybe it's because I'm not a baker okay
I'm not
they just do this for fun but here's the
question am I having fun right now I'm
not sure debatable
get some of this out it's too full three
let's try it one more time I have so
much stuff going on here
[Music]
these actually look pretty good so we're
gonna put these in the oven for 20
minutes and while these are baking I'm
going to make the glaze put on them 20
minutes hey Google set a timer for 20
minutes
donuts are cooking now it's time to make
the magical glaze it's actually quite
easy but I threw the directions away so
one second one and a half cups of
confectioner's sugar three to four
tablespoons of milk one tisp
of vanilla then victory oh we've got
this don't you worry
one in fact that of remotely measuring
this much with a popular something too
I'll do three let's see how that works
out oh my gotta get my vanilla hey you
do you think
very nice I think that is probably good
enough super sweet
okay Google how much time is left on my
timer six minutes and 51 seconds all
right wow they're looking good huh hmm
yeah that one's not so good I've prepped
my workspace I like to call this my my
kill zone going after the Dexter theme
oh I don't want to make a mess so I've
got everything nicely covered I've taped
down some parchment paper I've got these
sweet sweet little colors this is
colored powdered sugar I don't even know
how it's gonna work we're gonna go with
this color in this color for our switch
controllers and then we're gonna add in
a little these black sprinkles and then
I'm also gonna try to draw like the
joystick and the buttons
fingers crossed that this works out so
let's get all of our supplies
there's our inspiration
[Music]
here goes everything dunk this in there
oh wow I don't know what your sad I like
more so you need more icing check poke
out this whole little more so it looks a
little more donut II know I'm not gonna
do that that's a bad idea
so you got those two mm-hmm that's
that's something that just happened huh
[Music]
okay well uh oh
no it's funny because you know I love
getting the comments of fugu book in the
kitchen and this is what happens when I
get in the kitchen
it's a absolute disaster so I think you
probably should be telling you to get
out
quite working out the way that it should
be so just don't get it again oh this
looks beautiful
oh okay I've never used this before okay
I'm sorry
it's just just coming out real fast
that's a lot of powdered sugar
don't come one more time so I think
maybe what I did wrong is I need to just
like tap it a little bit yep yep okay
well I'm really honestly try okay this
is this is me trying these look like
absolute garbage I'm not proud of this
this looks stupid what even is this this
looks like an ant farm
we've got our red joy Khan over here
[Music]
there's no baking games coming in time
to switch because I will not I should
not touch those
[Music]
this looks like a watermelon this looks
like a blueberry and this looks like an
anthill well the good news is in my mind
these looked beautiful but in reality
this is what we've got
[Music]
alright let's try it
Oh surprisingly quite good mmm yeah
nice taste well I hope you guys enjoyed
this video I had so much fun making it
even though well it didn't turn out the
way that I had expected when the
beginning of the video you saw the
determination in my eye until the end
where you saw the defeat if you have
liked the video make sure you guys hit
like and stay tuned to my channel for an
unboxing of the new Nintendo switch as
soon as I get my hands on it I can not
wait so make sure you I subscribe so you
can stay tuned for that you guys can
follow me as I just seen on Instagram
snapchat Facebook Twitter let me know in
the comments below of what you guys
would like me to cook next feeling a
little ill from that bite over the
cupcake donut uh I don't need the
Hellboy I think I'm dying yeah don't
ever eat anything that I cook
[Music]